this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much and I've I brought my
little friend Prezi with me which I hope
all you teachers in the room are using
other than PowerPoint these days because
it doesn't have words it just has cool
little pictures which maybe it will
still put you to sleep um thank you so
much for having me I've been really
lucky to talk to students in a bunch of
places like Yale and Princeton and
Harvard and MIT in Santa Barbara and
Berkeley and UCLA and to public health
groups in wonderful conference places
like Disneyland or physicians dealing
with obesity and diabetes in places like
Saudi Arabia here for this recent talk
but I've never been able or allowed to
actually read from my book salt sugar
fat and I'm going to do that here today
too by the way I laugh every time I see
the cover because it was designed by
this crazy Russian emigre lives upstate
in New York who to do it went into his
your shoe store and pulled out his
favorite products off the shelf and
brought it back to a studio and hand
ripped the lettering out of them and
rearranged the letters to reflect what
is really going on about the products
that he and I am you probably to some
extent loved so deeply um which of
course is what the is what the book is
all about and I'm and I'm actually not
gonna read from the book but I'm going
to cite a couple of facts from it in
2002 the largest food company of all
Nestle paid 2.6 billion dollars for the
hot pocket brand that frozen
microwavable delicacy that became a
poster child for let's say exuberant
snacking and five years later
nestle acquired the rights to this drink
which helped it corner the market on one
of the grimmest results of over eating
every year in this country some 2,000
people undergo bariatric surgery to
physically shrink their stomach as a way
of helping them to actually eat less
so Gorge on the hot pocket get fat on
the hot pocket and then eat through a
tube was Nestle's marketing strategy if
you will get them fat get them thin it's
on page 337 of the book so imagine my
surprise now summer before last when I
got a call from none other than Nestle's
research and development organization on
the lovely shores of Lake Geneva asking
me to come give my book talk to their
secret gathering out secret private
gathering of 60 R&D people maybe 70 or
80 from all over the world that they had
they had gathered and and my first
reaction was what and when I told my son
Aaron who was with us in the audience
today about it his reaction was I hope
you're not spending my future tuition
money on a round-trip ticket to Geneva
because there's no way they're gonna let
you come back home they're probably
shove you off the Matterhorn but but
know that the R&D team had a new head
who convinced me that he was trying to
turn a corner at Nestle they had read
the book they were responding to
changing consumer demands and in order
for them to do good they needed to hear
more from people like me about all the
bad things that they have done and
remember though this is the richest
company in the food biz and so certainly
is from year to year Nestle is the own
of 29 of what it calls the billionaire
brands as one of its research scientists
put it to me
Nestle is the Swiss bank that prints
food but I decided to go in part because
I wanted to know what their 350 PhDs are
up to these days who work on exclusively
on food so I went I actually took Erin
with me as a as a bodyguard this is the
group right before I got up to give my
little spiel and and I'm giving you a
little bit of a shortened version of
what I said to what I said to Nestle um
and I started out with the fact that in
2008 I was actually in Algeria writing
of a jihadi militants when a couple of
FBI agents showed up at the New York
Times headquarters looking for me I had
been traveling to Iraq and to the Middle
East first tormenting the Pentagon for
failing to equip American and then Iraqi
soldiers with Armour and then looking at
how the war in Iraq was was fueling the
ability of recruiters in other parts of
the world to recruit new jihadis
like Abu Omar here whose job as he
showed me was building better and more
deadly IEDs to kill more Americans and I
had ended up in Algeria writing about
insurgents there when the newspaper
decided it was probably time for me to
come home and find something safer to do
and I mentioned this really only because
I went from one war to another I was
having coffee with my editor at the New
York Times on the 14th floor cafeteria
and I think I was still pitching her a
story about US armed sales overseas
something like that when she said to me
you know Michael what do you think about
peanuts
and I oh come on Christy I mean let me
tell you about these missiles and this
tear gas and it's going here and she
goes she goes no no listen to me
there's been an outbreak of Salmonella
in peanuts being manufactured by a
factory in Georgia on the Alabama border
and people are getting sick all over the
country and I'm still kind of de
meringue and she's going look Michael
think about it and an investigative
editors like to think of bass notes for
being potentially big stories to work on
it's just look you know these peanuts
aren't being manufactured by China or
some other far-off plates we can't blame
them for this one this is of our own
making thousands of people are being
sickened or even people starting to die
in most states across the country and
these peanuts are you being used by as
ingredients by this one trillion dollar
processed food industry about which we
really know very little and sure enough
when I went down to Georgia and spend
some time reporting on the ground that
outbreak became the story about how that
industry had lost control over its food
chain weeks and weeks were going by and
the largest companies were still trying
to figure out if they were using those
peanuts in their products and then
eventually recalling those products to
ensure safety of consumers and by
reporting on on food safety next took me
to to Minneapolis Minnesota where I was
incredibly lucky to come across a trove
of documents that allowed me for the
first time to tell the story of the
making of a hamburger
that's sickened many people because of
an e coli contamination including
Stephanie Smith here she was a 22 year
old dance instructor who had a burger at
her mom's house for Sunday supper one
week and a week later coming out of a
forced coma she was paralyzed from the
waist down because of the of the e.coli
in the hamburger and Stephanie allowed
me to sort of put a human face on this
trove of documents and the story of that
contamination
was an industry that intentionally
avoided knowing about its food chain in
order to avoid costly recalls they did
not want to trace back the hamburger
sources to to the slaughterhouses
because that would then be traced for to
other other manufacturers in this case
it was Cargill creating the hamburger
and I was I was having dinner with one
of my best sources Mansoor here who
tests pathogens for the meat industry
and by the way it was Mansoor who
Chipotle hired recently to turn its
company around from a food safety
standpoint immunity but he said to me
you know Michael is as tragic as these
episodes of contamination or you really
should look at what my industry you
started with the immunity is
intentionally adding to its products
over which it has absolute control and
he was talking about none other than
salt especially a huge in process meats
which got me thinking about sugar and
got me thinking about that as well and
so that that became the impetus to the
research and the reporting that took me
through for the book and and one of the
first things I had to grapple with was
well of course we already know that
eating too much of food I like to call
this stuff we hate to love can make us
you know unhealthily overweight and
otherwise ill but once again I was
amazingly lucky to come across a
mountain of documents emails and white
papers and memos and strategy papers
that put me at the table of the largest
food companies in the world as they were
formulating and strategizing and Marc
their products and it was those
documents that enabled me to identify
key players in those companies and then
convinced them to talk to me and open up
and tell me even more secrets about
their work and and the overwhelming
sense of that material in those
interviews which is which is what the
book is about is is a sense that this is
an industry that's driving 24/7 not just
to get us to not just like their
products but to want more and more of
them there's no word that they hate more
than than the a word addiction and they
will justifiably argue that look you
really can't compare you know Oreos with
with drugs or what have you and and I
think that there's some validity to that
but they don't even need to use the a
word and describing their efforts to
maximize the lure of their products they
talked about maximizing snack ability
and craveability
one of my favorite terms is more ich
nests these aren't English majors right
these are bench chemists marketing
people describing their efforts and look
it's it's not like it's also not like
this is this I view this as this evil
empire that intentionally set out to
make us overweight or otherwise you know
I mean these are companies doing what
all companies want to do which is to
make as much money as possible by
selling as much product as possible the
problem lies in their own sort of deep
dependence on using gobs of salt sugar
and fat to sort of get to that get to
that sort of ideal product and they're
in their eyes which is low-cost
convenient and utterly irresistible I
was incredibly lucky to spend time with
a legend in the industry in Howard
Moscow which was responsible for many of
the icons in the grocery store he was
trained in high math at Queens College
and then experimental psychology at
Harvard and and Howard walked me through
one of his recent creations which was a
new soda flavor
for dr. pepper in which he started with
no less than 60 versions of sweetness
each one just slightly different than
the next and subjected those to his
3,000 plus consumer taste tests around
the country and then took the data
through his computer did his high math
regression analysis thing and out came
typically charts like this at
bell-shaped curve where at the top of
the curve is not the dreaded middle C
you get in school but rather the perfect
amount of sweetness not too little not
too much it was Howard Moskowitz who
coined the term the Bliss point to
describe that perfect amount of
sweetness and when you talk to
nutritionists you realize that the
problem is not that the food industry
has created or in Howard's word
engineered Bliss points for things like
ice cream and cookies and soda things we
know and expect to be sweet it's that
they've marched around the grocery store
adding sugar to products that didn't
used to be sweet before so now breads
have added sugar and an engineered Bliss
point for sweetness some yogurts could
still have as much sugar per serving as
ice cream one of my favorite spots in
the grocery store is the pasta sauce
aisle where some brands can have the
equivalent of a couple of Oreo cookies
where the sweetness and a tiny half cup
serving and what this does is teach us
to expect sweetness and everything we
eat which is a real problem for kids
especially because they are born
hardwired for sweet taste so when you
drag them over to the produce aisle and
try to get them interested in things
like Brussels sprouts and celery and
broccoli you're going to get a rebellion
your hands but it's not just sugar of
course if if you were to draw a drug
analogy which I hesitate to do but if
you were to compare sugar to amphetamine
fat to the food industry is the opiate
for it's also very powerful very subtle
way of sneaking up on you now with a
Bliss point but with what the industry
calls the mouthfeel because as you all
know that's are still not quite accepted
as an official taste but rather that
sensation thanks to the trigeminal nerve
of biting into a warm toasted cheese
sandwich you can tell I'm a bit of a
salt and that guy because the reward
center of my brain is going off because
that's connected to their to the to the
pleasure centers of your brain just as
much as sugar is and one of the things
that industry learned with fad is I
write in the book that they could use
the excess processed cheese that they
were generating as an ingredient in
processed foods to increase the allure
of those products and so that's why
sandwich shops through a very strategic
joint venture between industry and the
government began offering and promoting
a market and cheese on every sandwich
you eat and you could walk through the
grocery store and so many products now
have added cheese in it not not cheese
for its own lovely sense of eating but
cheese as an added ingredient with those
those extra calories and then there's
salt of course which is a strange
creature I don't even know what the drug
analogy to salt is I mean these days
it's methadone because they're trying to
come up with salt substitutes right
because our salt consumption typically
is like so much higher than then
certainly some some scientists think we
we should be eating because of the the
links to high blood pressure and and and
heart disease but the real
I open air for me was was the moment
when I asked some of the larger food
companies why are you using so much salt
not in things I expect to be salty but
just in your across-the-board processed
foods and none of them Kellogg's invited
me in to show me what salt meant to them
and not only did I get to tour their Rd
Factory but they sat me down and
prepared for me special versions of some
of the biggest icons in the grocery
store without using any salt in them at
all and so we started with the we
started with the cheez-its which I
managed to take a little snapshot of
here normally I could eat those day-in
day-out but without salt
we couldn't even swallow them they taste
they stuck rather to the roof of our
mouth because salt adds texture and
solubility we moved on to the frozen
waffles put them in the toaster and they
came out looking and tasting like straw
because salt adds color and flavor and
then we moved on to the cornflakes put
them in the bowl added some water taste
it took it took a took a bite and before
I could say anything the chief spokesman
for the company was sitting there she
gets this look of horror on her face and
she swallows and blurts out the word
metal I taste metal and et al and the
chief technical officer is there and he
starts chuckling he goes yeah not not
everybody will get this but one of the
one of the beautiful things that makes
salt such a miracle
ingredient to us is that it will mask
some of the off notes bad tastes that
are inherent to some processed foods in
this case some of the added minerals to
the cornflakes would give you what I had
a sensation of one of my fillings coming
loose and sloshing around in my mouth
and that's what I really got it which is
as dependent
as we've become on large amounts of salt
sugar fat the industry itself is even
more dependent on them which is a real
problem for it now because those same
companies like Nestle are now trying to
change but I went on with nestling I
said look as you guys know it's not just
salt sugar but it's the marketing of
course that goes into the products and
increasingly marketing people began to
run the largest food companies I had a
wonderful time with edy Martin who was
part of a SWAT team at Kellogg's I'm
when they were losing market share to
General Mills and he told me how they
sat around one day and they schemed up
this thing called rice krispies treats
cereal and they they they and and they
thought that's a great idea
let's give it to the technicians and let
them work it out and the poor
technicians came back and pulling their
hair out said we can't do it I mean
every time we tried to add marshmallow
to the cereal it turns to mush and
wishes the death of cereal so the
marketing people went back to their
consumer panel and said look we can't
quite do this guys help us out and they
said well look you don't really have to
give us marshmallow you you you can
probably just give us the sensation of
marshmallow the taste the flavor or the
smell and that'll be powerful enough for
us in the court the industry coined the
term permission we will give you
permission to fool us if you just get
close enough to the real thing rice
krispies treats cereal without the real
marshmallows became a huge hit for for
Kellogg's I spent a whole chapter on the
Lunchables because it's just it's just
absolutely fascinating I got to meet and
spend lots of time with the inventor of
the Lunchables Bob bran who who just you
know who's still amazed to this day that
they managed to turn you know little
pieces of processed cheese and processed
meat and crackers
think nobody would be even interested in
eating necessarily into a billion dollar
a year brand that kids would get excited
about but at one point in the process
they learned and decided and were sort
of known for saying among themselves
that that they realized that Lunchables
wasn't about the food as much as it was
the badge value the the the great buzz
that gave to the kid who pulled one of
these Lunchables out on the lunchroom he
or she became the cat's meow of the
lunchroom and so they came up with that
slogan for the kids all day you got to
do what they say but lunchtime is all
yours the food industry is incredibly
smart about hitting finding and hitting
those emotional buttons which really for
a for much of the time is what drives us
to to to eat and then of course there
was Jeffery done for 20 years he was the
fiercest warrior at this company he rose
to become president of coca-cola for
North America South America
Jeffrey done walked me through cokes
pioneering of the supersize me phenomena
where they they decided they could make
more money by offering unlimited amounts
of drink soda Coca Cola to people in
restaurants because really the
ingredients didn't cost more even for
the mega sizes though the warlike
language they used in their competition
with Pepsi where they would refer to
their best customers people who would
drink two or three cokes a day or more
not as their best customers but as heavy
users and and they're targeting of
people like tatianna here who I caught
up with in a corner store in
Philadelphia knowing that when kids walk
into a store with a little bit of their
own spending money and make those first
decisions about what to buy they will
become
printed on that product on that brand
and that's why coke the envy of solid
food manufacturers around the world
focused so hard on putting cokes in the
hands of kids at ballparks knowing that
sort of that joyous moment of the kid
being with their parent and getting that
product in their hand it was worth was
worth gazillions and advertising in
implanting that that wonderful memory
and in the kids head and of course
there's the analogy to tobacco which
isn't just an analogy many of us have
forgotten but back in the 1980s the
largest tobacco company in North America
eventually the world became the largest
food manufacturer Philip Morris through
its acquisition of General Foods the old
food conglomerate out of New York and
Kraft and I was lucky to spend time with
some of the some of the former CEOs of
Philip Morris explaining to me how they
lent some of their marketing practices
for cigarettes to their food managers at
Kraft and General Foods which also led
me to write about in the beginning of
the book sort of this this wonderfully
powerful moment back in 1999 when the
heads of the largest food companies got
together privately by brought together
by couples of insiders within their own
companies who were becoming increasingly
concerned about their culpability in the
growing obesity not just obesity but
other health crisis and up before them
stands a senior official at the biggest
company of all Kraft he's armed with 72
slides including this one here that he's
showing to the CEO and he lays at their
feet responsibility not just for the
growing obesity situation but diabetes
gout several types of cancers and he
pleads with the eggs
negatives to start doing something
meaningful to turn a corner and in part
reformulate their products to be truly
healthier he sits down and as I write in
the book one of the biggest most
powerful CEOs and REM stands up and is
visibly angry and says look we are
already insensitive to what consumers
want if they want a loaf at this or a
low sugar this we make it it's on the
Shelf there they have options but you've
got to remember that we are also
beholden to shareholders and there is no
way we're going to mess around with the
company Jules referring to salt sugar
fat if that's if that's going to lead to
lower sales because we would not be
responsible than to those shareholders
and by and large that's still the basic
story of the food industry today even
though it's changing oh and because it
was Nestle I reminded them that they
were sending boats like this up and down
the Amazon finding new ways to market
their products to people who were still
entirely cooking by scratch figuring out
they could they could sell many versions
of their products and all the big
companies are doing it to the emerging
middle class in in Brazil and then I sat
down and I spent the next two days at
Nestle up by the way to some mild mildly
Pleasant applause from the the RMT
people spending time with them looking
at sort of what they were doing to
reformulate their products and I have to
say it was it was fairly impressive I
mean they're taking their there they're
trying to minimize or reduce the amount
of salt that they're using by by taking
it out of products internally and
concentrating it on the surface of
product so it provides that that that
what the industry calls flavor burst
sort of immediately to the target that's
is live in the reward center so you get
basically more bang for your buck they
showed me how they were taking fat
globules and expanding the surface area
so you would have more contact of the
fat with your mouth for again bigger
mouthfeel bang for the for the buck and
of course how they were trying to
replace caloric sweeteners with with
non-caloric sweeteners in changing some
of their products like like the hot
pockets but but here's kind of the rub
and and in in some ways I have a bit of
a confession too because as much as I
focused on salt sugar fat and as much as
I talked about the solution to the
problem of companies adding too much
salt sugar fat is obviously reducing the
salt sugar fat when you talk to
nutritionists
that's typically not the first thing
that they say to you the first thing
they will say to is that we all need to
be doubling the amount of this stuff
that we eat and if we do that we're
going to be way more than halfway home
to to better health from the food that
we have and and and kind of even the
rest of the stuff will start to some
extent taken care of of itself and so I
started in and when I asked nicely about
that in their sciences and said look
okay I appreciate that you're reducing
the salt sugar and fat in these products
but but what are you doing to stuff the
hot pockets with this stuff I got a
blank stare because in fact that's one
of the most difficult things for the
processed food industry now which is not
decreasing the bad boy ingredients in
their products its increasing the good
stuff is a real challenge for them
and so I started thinking about well
what would what would my food UI ANSYS
use the possessive
what would my food Giants do they
suddenly had to start selling fresh
vegetables and fruit and then and then
and the cynics among us would probably
guess well they would smother them with
cheese sauce or fried caramel glazing
but no if the rules was it had to sell
produce as it was without ruining the
nutritional profile of this what would
they do and I'm convinced they would
sort of go to their tried-and-true three
things that make processed food so so
successful they would make it more
convenient they would make it they would
make it more more lower kata they would
lower the cost of it and they would do
things to make it if not irresistible at
least more interesting in order to
increase consumption and I think
probably you know for the for the for
the lower the cost they would go to the
agricultural community and say hey guys
remember how we told you to grow
soybeans and field corn which are the
staples of our foods forget that we want
you to grow fresh vegetables and fruits
now and sure enough in the Midwest I ran
across AG extension programs which were
teaching field corn and soybean farmers
how to switch over to grow vegetables
and increase um increased supply if not
demand and that way um low and behold I
also ran across your very own Thomas
björkman here who is working on the R&D
end of things because last time I looked
the industry was spending two billion
dollars a year on research and
development to make soy and corn more
profitable for farmers and I had trouble
coming up with a mere hundred million
dollars in research and development for
all vegetables and fruits and that's an
that's an uneven
playing fuel that's very significant so
I'm convinced that my food Giants would
increase the amount of money they put
into research into science to make
vegetables more attractive more tasty
fresher more long-lasting if you will in
the shelf and and then also I'm
convinced that they would sort of fiddle
around with the grocery store and I ran
across these these guys in New Mexico
practicing nudge marketing they were
going into supermarkets and fiddling
with the grocery cart and they did some
experiments where they in fact these
these one of these one of these
scientists came out of the Cornell Food
Lab actually call him Paine and did an
experiment where he put some duct tape
down the middle of a grocery cart and a
sign in the front saying put your
vegetables in the front half of the
shopping cart in that little nudge led
to a doubling in produce sales in the
grocery stores where they did this
experiments but he also was playing
around when I caught up with him by
putting with putting mirrors in the
front of the car because the idea is
when you walk into the grocery store
everything about it is designed to sort
of get you off your game plan and make
spontaneous purchase decisions and to
kind of forget about who you are so his
idea was if we could remind people of
who they were as they're shopping in the
store they'll reconnect kind of with the
consequences of those purchase decisions
and remember the reality outside the
store and said what you get is this law
law music and and bright colors and
again sort of this law law atmosphere so
he started picturing and I love this one
because this is a this photo is
reflecting the image of the person
pushing the cart he was in El Paso and
the mirror that they had come up with
was was was sort of was rectangular and
he had suggested turning it this way so
he would get the image of
this part of his body because he had a
very substantial stomach but the real
biggest thing I think that the food
joints would do to increase consumption
those fruits and vegetables would be to
turn to their tried and true friends on
Madison Avenue and find those emotional
buttons to push that could drive
consumption of vegetables like they
drive consumption of Snickers bars and
what have you so it took a while but I
managed to find an advertising firm to
do an ad campaign for me for a vegetable
and and and not any vegetable but I
settled on a vegetable that tends to
tends to cause issues for a good number
of people especially of my generation if
they had parents who cooked it to mush
and then made you and then made you eat
it and not only that but this
advertising agency agreed to do this
campaign and let me watch them do it and
videotape it and it was like being
inside a mad man and woman segment and
we're there where they're doing their
sort of genius thing and so I'm going to
show you a couple of snippets of of the
video that we made of their process
trying to come up with this this
campaign for the problem vegetable
I hope you remember that guy okay and
about halfway through the process and
this one not for weeks and weeks I mean
these are people who can turn around and
ad for Porsche in like a couple of days
but they were pulling their hair out and
because this was like a real challenge I
mean it's one thing to sell junky stuff
or speed or sex to people but broccoli
but at one point they decided okay look
Michael you're not giving us any money
but even in the real world we probably
wouldn't have money for primetime TV we
got to like to start slowly here let's
let's do some social media campaign
stuff and let's we're gonna pick a fight
with another product in the grocery
store and I thought oh boy they're gonna
go after you know one of my favorites
potato chips or maybe they're gonna go
out there french fries in the restaurant
and they go no no no no you're
forgetting your own book remember how
you wrote about how the supposed Pepsi
and coca-cola was like a bloody war and
in fact it was totally bloodless because
those two companies figured out that
every time they attacked each other or
every time Pepsi got Michael Jackson to
come up with a new ad the sales of both
companies would rise because it brought
buzz to the soda aisle and so they
decided to pick a fight with
butI else in the grocery store and this
is a video snippet of these mad men and
women actually at work sitting around
the table trying to come up with this
with this
so that drops out at the end but he said
is it a bro k so this is how these might
you know advertising people you know get
their juices up by sitting around
thinking of silly things like that but
in fact they came up with a campaign I
came up with a story this is it landed
on the cover that every times magazine
and then still I'm still kind of amazed
that the New York Times editors put it
on in the magazine not to mention on the
cover because it was entirely fictitious
there was no campaign there was no
broccoli grower that was buying this
advertising for their product but we did
it and this is one of the ad strategies
and boy did I hear it from the kale
people all right and I'm still hearing
it from the kale people but they were
having fun and that was that was the
first lesson that they learned
themselves and they relate to me which
is the last thing in the world we're
gonna do is preach about broccoli
because the government has been
preaching about broccoli to us for years
and years and sales have an increase
we're gonna have fun and we're gonna
recreate broccolis image to consumers
but then something really interesting
happened some students at another
college I want mention but it happens to
be in New Haven one of the one of the
biggest food deserts in the country
right a university surrounded by fairly
poor people without a lot of shopping
options
decided to take the campaign advertising
that victor's and spoils didn't create
real billboards and real signs and they
managed to double broccoli sales and new
even with their real hands-on strategy
one of the V rather largest broccoli
grower on the East Coast adopted the
Alpha vegetable strategy that Victor's
and Spoils came up with having seen that
broccoli was a bit of a Wallflower timid
they decided to make it big and bold and
dramatic and addy thanks to Thomas this
is one of their broccoli boxes and you
can go to their website and see a whole
bunch of others sort of advertising
strategy they're using and then the
Obama let's move campaign people got the
the produce Association folks interested
in doing something even more
dramatically powerful which was engaging
some of our celebrities who endorsed the
junky estroux products out there to turn
around and lend their good name and good
faces to things like broccoli and and in
this case in this case citrus and and
it's taking off the produce Association
is actually now doing two experimental
programs in two cities where they're
trying to measure the ability of this
kind of advertising campaign to to
increase sales and I think that I'm
hoping that if that data is as strong it
is is they'll be able to convince the
produce growers themselves to start
coughing up money for marketing again
look there's no there's no way that skit
that that spinach is ever gonna be able
to compete with skittles for that reward
center of our brain but they don't
really have to match it just get close
to it to have some dramatic impact in
the grocery store where other things can
happen to none other than Walmart I I
heard the other day
and some of its stores in West Virginia
were rejiggering the physical layout of
grocery stores to increase the presence
of vegetables and I'll show you a little
segment of this it's all I'm going to
show you because the answer is they
increase sales and it was working
because the checkout counter is actually
one of the most dangerous places in the
shopper if you're thinking about health
because the stores know that that's when
your guard is down and you're much more
apt to impulse buy and so that's why the
soda companies started planting
refrigerators there with sodas that you
could buy at the last moment which
brings me to this incredible sort of
moment we're in now where we have this
huge number of startup companies run in
some cases by people from Silicon Valley
other cases food AG people like here at
Cornell who are trying to to use that
awful word disrupt or reinvent sort of
all segments of the grocery store and
it's it's really sort of fun watching
them try to do their thing some of them
are coming up with products like this
which is Soylent the drink right but
others are coming up with really
interesting things like this sort of
reformulating a ketchup to substitute
all the added sugar with like real
vegetables instead and in this case the
guys who invented that are a couple of
military veterans from the Iraq war and
the stuff actually tastes really good
but one of the things that I'm most
excited about is a number of the people
I wrote about in the book who brought us
things like the Lunchables and coca-cola
and rice krispie treats cereal have now
switched
having having some considerable
misgiving about their life work and they
are now helping some of the startups
scale up by lending some of their hard
core formulation and marketing
strategies to these new companies
so Jeffrey Dunn of coca-cola Fame right
started putting baby carrots in vending
machines and using advertising like the
broccoli campaign to make baby carrots
fun ed Martin the guy who invented the
rice krispies treats cereal for
Kellogg's is all excited about these
things which are cargo containers you
can plop into any food desert these were
actually started to be used by pot
growers but he's got the idea of using
them for lettuce throw a little solar
panels on the roof and you have instant
year-round accessible and hopefully
affordable greens and then there's
Dennis Serra Britto
from the victors and spoils broccoli
campaign who you saw Sarah is pictured
here on backing up sorry here's Sarah
Sarah I worked for Kraft and one of her
one of her biggest hits was figuring out
how to increase sales of mac and cheese
and and as Sarah tells it she was
surveying neighborhoods I think it was
in Denver and she walked into one
family's house and they were sitting
around talking and and she said she said
to them kind of confiding that hey we
were just at your neighbors and they
were telling us how much they loved
kraft mac and cheese and this light bulb
went on in the people she was talking to
and they said really and that's when
Sara sort of understood that they could
market this as this shared secret among
consumers and so she came up with this
campaign you know you love it
well Sara is now working for a group
called the chef's collect
bunch of people in the restaurant
industry cooks and what-have-you who are
trying to in reinvent restaurant menus
and the foods and restaurants to make
them just as delicious but healthier for
people a really treacherous part of the
of our food chain right now in terms of
changing people's habits and then
there's Bob drain inventor of the of
before spoken Lunchables
he has started advising a young man
named Luke Saunders who is trying to
disrupt what are the more difficult
and/or treacherous parts of the food
system in this country the bending
machine Luke by the way was a was an was
a Mike it was a industrial oil salesman
working in the Midwest when he went into
a food factory that was making frozen
crustless peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches and Luke said what parent
would serve these to their kids and and
the manager said it's not parents the
schools are buying this because they no
longer have kitchens to cook real food
and Luke just kind of goes that it's
gotta be like a better way to do some of
this food stuff Luke came up with the
farmers fridge salad vending machine
which is actually working it's fresh
salad it's affordable he's got 30 or a
hundred of these in the Chicago area now
poor people wealthier people are buying
them and Bob drain is helping him sort
of rethink the marketing strategy for
the farmers fridge and it's a little
scary because because drain is about you
know things like captive audiences and
he goes to Luke you know look you're
putting these at 7-elevens but but
people drive to the 7-eleven and that
means they can drive down the street to
Burger King you're not you
to lose a lot of those people why don't
you park these things in like a big
office building where you have a captive
audience a targeted captive audience and
it's the it's this hardcore expression
that maybe maybe a little scary for food
starter people who aren't used to
thinking about their lovely product and
in that fashion
um this by the way is the original
strategic marketing for for lunchable
that made it so focused and so cunning
and Bob is trying to help Lou come up
with a sort of similar marketing
strategy for the for the Lunchables and
who knows I mean eventually I think that
going back to Nestle that if you could
use the tried-and-true food industry
methods of luring cost increasing
convenience and increasing demand that
you'll not just get more produce sales
in the produce aisle I think you'll get
the food joints themselves more keen on
using more vegetables and/or fruits in
their products throughout the grocery
store so you don't have to do the
Walmart thing and put bananas at the
checkout counter you can have the
essence of those bananas and food
products where you don't anymore today
and all the lovely nutritional value of
that of course there's always the food
giant's and they are trying their best
now to reinvent their products - this
was a recent tasting in in Williamsburg
Brooklyn where Kellogg's had a stand
where they were adding things like pork
fat to Rice Krispies cereal which is
sort of their way of trying to reinvent
their products and who knows they may
succeed in some ways maybe this maybe
that or maybe they'll just go back to
this sort of tried-and-true method - but
I think that with a little bit of help
from the food giants in there
marketing strategies a lot of these
startups themselves can really start
scaling up and make a really big
difference in our eating habits and and
public health as a result of that and
lastly I always forget that
but this rather but as I work on the
next book I'm it's still out there
engaging with people and tweeting
through this address so if any of you
want to keep in touch with me on that on
that scale I'd be glad to
and that's all I have thank you so much
sure yeah but the other beautiful thing
about about fruits and vegetables is you
can do some processing you can freeze
for example and then one of my favorite
things to buy this time of year frozen
blueberries which if frozen correctly
can actually make a lot more ethical
moral sense health sense than trying to
buy fresh blueberries imported from who
knows where so I think there's actually
a lot of cunning processing that the
industry could do it and look look I
mean processing is not necessarily an
evil word and and and certainly I'm not
about about being anti all food
processing otherwise I wouldn't be
eating my favorite cheese's for example
um it's about it's about controlling
processed foods rather than letting them
control us and I think that that knowing
is the food industries know that more
and more people are caring about what
they put in their bodies and they're
they're starting to make purchase
decisions based on that I think they'll
understand that they can't they can't
ruin those things and they may be able
to incorporate them into into into
products you know where people need some
convenience in their in their lives yeah
the good news is that I think in many
other countries including France there's
sort of more mindfulness about food and
I and I know that the folks at the food
lab here at Cornell it's really paid
close attention to that issue of
mindfulness because it does seem to be
does seem like there was this moment in
the 1980s when suddenly overnight we
became mindless about food and and it
became socially acceptable to eat
anything anywhere at any time and that's
when you started people see people walk
down the street and eating and drinking
and bringing food into business meetings
and if I open up a bag of chips right
now and a little snack you probably
wouldn't be that shocked and that played
right into the hands of the food
companies and making us less mindful
about them and so they started to
engineer products you could eat with one
hand
didn't need utensils while you were
doing something something else and that
led to snacking becoming this fourth
American meal I mean in France still
people think we're crazy just I mean why
would you want to ruin your appetite
before having a meal where you were
gonna sit down with friends and family
and linger for a couple of hours
enjoying kind of the sociability as well
as the food itself it's changing though
but because American processed foods are
starting to spread around the world not
just to Saudi Arabia or Brazil where I
showed Nestle's both but in Europe as
well and so you're seeing increasing
obesity and diabetes and in in lots of
the developed world as well where the
convenience in the allure of processed
foods and or kind of the craziness of
their lives is is making them more
dependent on American style processed
foods alright um yeah I think
potentially but but and you know I used
to I used to really I used to really
hate the idea of the soda tax as being
regressive and hurting poor people who
you know you know or paying the tax but
but I sort of come around on that but
but it's funny because I I put that
question to Jeff Bible the former CEO
Philip Morris and in his Australian
accent which I can't mimic he said to me
you know Michael look I'm no fan of
government but but when it comes to food
I mean you have to remember these food
companies are so bish ously competitive
for space on the grocery shelf and and
people are becoming so concerned about
food these days that I think it could
actually be who the food companies to to
take it upon themselves actually to
suggest some regulation relating to
nutrition if only to sort of give them
cover from wall
because they're all under tremendous
pressure to produce profits and that
pressure is has just increased year
after year after year and that was sort
of Jeff Bible sense was it would be in
the industry's own interest to sort of
reach out but I don't think they're
gonna accept it coming the other way and
I think that's just this inherent
resistance to to having government
intervention especially if it doesn't
make any sense to the food companies I'd
much rather see the change come from the
food companies themselves finding ways
to continue making money with healthier
products and and I think they're
starting they're starting to try this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu